Bonne fête des pères !
C'était beaucoup trop agressif comme entrée.
Aujourd'hui c'est le jour des explications, c'est aussi le jour de la fête des pères, c'est aussi un dimanche.
Je vais donc vous expliquer un tour que vous allez pouvoir faire à votre père, pour la fête des pères.
Et ce matin, en me réveillant, j'ai eu une idée particulière.
Je vous propose un tour interactif, entre votre père et moi, par votre intermédiaire.
Je vais donc commencer par vous apprendre le tour, comme ça vous allez pouvoir le faire à votre père.
Pour faire le tour je mets un petit PDF dans le descriptif de la vidéo, que vous pouvez télécharger.
Et comme finalité du tour, vous faites voir à votre père soit mon dernier Snap, soit mon dernier Tweet, soit mon dernier message sur Facebook
que ce soit sur la fan page ou sur le profil, ou encore sur Instagram.
Pour tous les réseaux sociaux, vous les avez aussi dans le descriptif de la vidéo.
Et c'est dans le message qu'il lira que tour prendra tout son sens.
Par contre si jamais vous préférez que je lui fasse le tour moi-même, je vais vous le faire en vidéo.
Vous, si vous préférez le faire à votre père vous même, ce qui serait beaucoup mieux, vous aurez juste à répéter ce que j'ai fait dans la vidéo.
Mais si jamais vous n'osez pas le faire, vous avez juste à lui faire voir la vidéo, à partir du moment où je vais claper.
Avec le YouTube clap.
Je pense que tout ça est clair et limpide.
Pour commencer vous devez demander à votre père de prendre un papier, un crayon. Et vous, préparez votre téléphone en mode calculatrice.
Vous allez voir, c'est plus pratique.
Bonne fête des pères !
Première !
Bonjour à vous, heureux papa. Je m'appelle Fabien Olicard, je suis mentaliste.
Et oui, votre fils ou votre fille passe beaucoup de temps apparemment à regarder mes vidéos.
Et on a préparé quelque chose ensemble, pour essayer de vous mentaliser, comme ça, à travers l'écran.
Vous devez absolument avoir près de vous, un papier et un crayon et peut-être un téléphone portable en fonction calculatrice.
Ça vous servira après.
Je vais vous demander de penser, et même d'écrire un nombre à quatre chiffres.
Ça peut être n'importe quelle suite de quatre chiffres.
Ça peut être votre code secret de carte bleue. Et ne croyez pas que vos enfants ne le connaissent pas.
Ça peut être votre date de naissance, ça peut être les quatre derniers chiffres de votre numéro de téléphone.
Peu importe, vous écrivez un nombre à quatre chiffres.
Une fois que vous l'avez écrit, vous vous concentrez sur ces quatre chiffres et vous allez les mélanger dans votre tête, dans l'ordre que vous voulez.
Ca vous donne un nouveau nombre à quatre chiffres.
Et vous allez l'écrire juste en dessous.
Exemple concret:
J'avais écrit: 3787, je pouvais écrire en dessous: 7837.
Ce sont les mêmes chiffres, mais mis dans un ordre différent.
Vous maitrisez tout, c'est vous qui prenez toutes les décisions.
Je vous laisse faire, un tout petit peu... ça doit être bon. C'est bon ?!
Plus que deux étapes et on va faire un petit retour dans le passé.
Vous allez maintenant soustraire le plus grand nombre, par le plus petit nombre.
C'est pas nécessairement le premier par le deuxième, ou le deuxième par le premier.
Dans on exemple, je ferai: 7837-3787.
[rires] Je me marre, parce que je me dis si il y a une personne en France qui a choisi les mêmes numéros que moi, ça doit être hyper flippant de l'autre coté de l'écran !
Ça vous donne donc un nouveau résultat qui est issu de votre choix de départ, des 4 chiffres, et de votre manière de mélanger.
C'est vous qui avez décidé tout ça !
Et pour créer votre nombre final, on va faire un petit peu de numérologie.
Votre enfant connaît bien la numérologie, il peut vous aider.
Vous allez tout simplement additionner tous les chiffres du résultat de votre addition ensemble.
Par exemple, si je devais faire de la numérologie sur ce résultat là, je ferai: 3+1=4, 4+4=8, 8+5=13.
Faites ce petit calcul, et vous avez un résultat maintenant en tête, le votre.
C'est rien que le votre.
Vous pouvez l'écrire si vous avez peur de l'oublier. C'est avec celui-ci qu'on va jouer, en retournant un petit peu dans le passé.
A une époque où il n'y avait pas de vidéos sur les téléphones, pourquoi ? Parce qu'il n'y avait pas de smartphones.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous avez connu, et j'ai connu, je vous rassure, les téléphones à cadran.
On avait ça. Quand on devait composer tous les numéros, surtout quand c'était souvent dans les 9 et qu'on se planter dans le dernier, et qu'on était obligé de tout refaire depuis le départ !
J'ai connu ça, on a eu un téléphone à touches que tardivement chez moi aussi.
Moment nostalgie. Je vous remets un cadran à l'ancienne juste ici.
Et voici ce que vous allez faire:
Vous allez compter avec votre doigt, en faisant le nombre de cercles qu'il faudra, autant de fois que le nombre final que vous avez eu après la numérologie.
Vous allez donc poser votre doigt sur le 1, en comptant 1.
Ensuite sur le 2, en comptant 2.
Sur le 3, en comptant 3...etc, etc...
Et vous vous arrêtez forcément sur une touche particulière, la votre.
Celle qui correspond à votre nombre numérologique, qui a était issue d'une soustraction, entre des chiffres que vous avez choisi au départ
qui ont eu du sens pour vous et des soustractions, et un mélange de chiffres qui a été votre choix aussi.
Je vous laisse faire.
Allez-y.
Faites-le.
Et comme on ne va pas attendre tout le temps, mettez pause pour le faire, on sera plus tranquille.
Et on reprend juste après.
Voilà. Vous vous êtes arrêté sur une des cases du téléphone.
Vous avez donc un nombre en tête et aussi 3 lettres, les 3 lettres associées.
Je vais vous demander juste de retenir le nombre et les trois lettres associées.
Et maintenant, je laisse la place à votre fils ou votre fille, suivant à qui vous faites le tour,
qui va vous emmener sur l'un de mes réseaux où j'ai mis un petit message à votre intention.
J'espère que ce petit moment qu'on vous a organisé, avec votre enfant vous a plu.
Passez une très bonne fête des pères !
Attention ! Fin du tour.
🎬
Voilà, comme je vous ai dit je vous mets un PDF dans le descriptif, où je reprends en quelques mots, les étapes que vous devez suivre pour faire le tour,
et également le cadran, vous pouvez imprimer tout ça.
Et comme ça, vous le faites à votre père aujourd'hui.
Et vous avez compris que si vous vous sentez pas de le faire vous même, vous lui faites voir la vidéo.
Ensuite vous l'emmenez sur mes réseaux sociaux, n'importe lequel.
Il y a tous les liens dans le descriptif également, comme tous les jours.
Et puis voilà ! On aura fait un truc ensemble, pour la fête des pères. Je trouve ça cool !
Par contre si jamais vous regardez cette vidéo après le 19 juin, sachez que pour voir la finalité du tour,
vous allez sur n'importe lequel de mes réseaux sociaux, et vous allez voir le poste du 19 juin.
Je n'en mettrai qu'un seul, ce sera celui-là.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu !
Alors oui aujourd'hui je ne porte pas un t-shirt rigolo, parce qu'il fait beaucoup trop froid.
On est le 19 juin et je me les gèle, donc j'ai mis un pull.
N'hésitez pas à laisser un petit commentaire en bas de la vidéo. Je les lis tous, tout le temps, et j'aime bien vous lire, vraiment.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, vous pouvez la gratifier d'un magnifique...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
D'ici là, passez un excellent dimanche. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !